afternoon
[Applause]
songs
changing
oh
Gamestar shut up
Deez Nuts
then block me
man is gerited
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I want to introduce I want to welcome
Eli and Ethan Klein
yeah
yeah [__] [__]
thank you
Friday
baby I can't even tell if it's on you
guys are so [__] loud holy [__]
wow
wow her insane energy
holy [__]
all right God damn
all right chill chill
[Applause]
it's the weekend baby it's the weekend
yeah it's Friday [__] [__]
[Applause]
let's [__] go
all right
who the [__] is Uncle game who the [__]
is
up game
[Applause]
dude you got too good at this game I'm
never gonna win again this guy right
here Uncle game [__] [__] white
Club [__] white cloth
[__] white cloth [__] white claw [__]
white Club
all right thank you Gabe thank you
all right
thank you guys everyone for being here
um this is incredible this is amazing
the energy is insane and I'm just really
happy
to be here and
it's gonna be awesome
we got a great show planned for a change
so Ela is here obviously the beautiful
Ela
you want to stand up
throw it off oh my God okay okay okay
chill Vin Diesel [__] damn
all right guys
wait who said that
yeah thank you guys for noticing still a
couple of pounds to lose but you know
all right guys let's get this uh show
started and with that
I introduce
the hardest working
funniest sweetest greatest crew members
a man could ever dream to hope for
come out
[Applause]
Jim Cameron and they're all here
they're all here better
[Applause]
uh Dan is back in the command Studio
he's actually has a job unlike all of us
up here
Dad is working yes
and Dan um are you yeah
Dan Dan can you talk do you have a mic
there he is
how are you feeling our Tech is it the
tech all squared away
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up chat
all right so um well let me say hi to
the crew I mean you guys all look
amazing
amazing beautiful
uh Zach how are you are you how you
doing today I'm feeling great how are
you feeling
what's that I'm feeling great how are
you feeling I'm good
you build any of like Legos recently
some good Lego sets yeah dude uh you
know a lot of great stuff coming out uh
you look great by the way I just got to
give you a round thank you yeah thank
you so much appreciate that
yeah so did you learn any new like
chords on the guitar I don't know how
that works is there New Ports do they
discover new chords uh you can you know
you just got to figure it out and play
but uh you know it's a good old time
I've been playing so long that uh you
know you figure it out right
that I didn't understand any of that
but you look great better than usual a
lot better than yourself I mean holy
[__]
I got a haircut yeah so um
at the moment love is trying to connect
via Sweden
as you can see
we are killing it
device is not connected to a network
click here to learn more
create or sign into your Amazon account
it's the little things isn't it
is it
okay
we want love
all right anyway forget about that
so how you guys doing let's talk to the
to the crew a little bit uh you guys
have been here since 11 A.M thank you
amazing they're the best
they are the best
um
how is my door breaking I couldn't break
it off the hinges but I did break it
cheers my dude okay Zach you're gonna
have to chill out those are [__] too
loud
you got you gotta
okay this TV is really becoming an issue
we're trying to bring love in it's not
it's not working look
no homo
homo love you love
okay
we've hit our first snag here
[Music]
Ela
so excited yeah actually oh I just got
the most annoying message I mean it's
not that bad
[Applause]
there he is love is connecting in from
Sweden thank you love I know the time
Zone's crazy
sorry actually exciting news
um love finally got a date on his Visa
he's coming in next month so when we
come back for break
what is that
someone in there
what is it
[Applause]
I don't know what that is
okay
[Applause]
he's here oh what's up everyone
he's here he's been here the whole
[__] time
thank you
um he's been here the whole time and by
the way you detectors on the subreddit
you fox
you guys figure this out like on Monday
because there was a little bit of green
around his hair so annoying you guys are
way too
I don't know and you care less please
Jesus Christ please actually love has
been here for a little bit of time and
it's been challenging to keep him kind
of undercover because if he goes outside
I mean the chances somebody sees him and
sees a picture it's just too high of a
risk
so um we
so we prepared a bit of a mini
docu-series
I don't know if you called that
but uh are we ready to roll that Dan
[Music]
all right I think this is the place
yo what the hell let me in bro hold on
hold on give me a sec
parting the curtain dramatic welcomed in
Welcome to My Crib what's up you're CR
yeah this is my house welcome in why are
you wearing a bathrobe over a hoodie
what's that about what do you mean
instead of fresh it's my parents parents
company your parents company oh okay
this is where I live now this right here
is my king-sized bed come over to my my
kitchen here the massive juice from
Gooser fridge fully stocked of course oh
and oh don't forget the the snack
cabinet the DVD player on hand if you do
that's kitchen you're really talking
like this is your house I don't think
this is not your house no this miles
you're not meant to be here very long
right I'm not gonna I'm I live here
here's my uh dinner table Yeah breakfast
lunch yeah something like that something
uh I don't know why not dinner you
probably want to throw those away right
these these were here when I bought the
house when you bought the house yeah the
story keeps changing that's very
interesting I'm curious what Ethan
thinks about that every single uh break
here is actually a pearl from the sea
rainforest uh drip juice or shower do
you want to see the outside feels weird
to be in here I feel like I know it is
to be here but I don't know if you are
either really what I mean is this like
um like the other part of my house just
oh like over there yeah that's my that's
my the other part of the house like the
the back shed yeah
yeah don't don't mind the the things
here it's my just my brothers what's
your brother's name
um Teddy right here we like to call it
the garden you know people talk about
the Garden of Eden more about the garden
of Sweden am I right Sweden Garden of
Love You can just you can just eat me
right off the vine huh wow I come back
here to relax and think about clips and
such so we're in the actual house now I
don't know if we're meant to be in here
this is also like my second kitchen here
it's a new house I just got it I'll just
grab this I don't think you've ever
opened that cabinet in your life no I I
stock these cabinets myself I'm a big
coffee drinker that was here for me
that's my coffee oh oh yeah I poured it
up for you yeah here you go I don't
think he poured it up yeah yeah I don't
know if that's the word I'd use anyways
you're just taking her coffee my coffee
yeah I can show you down here okay yeah
yeah the office where I do a lot of work
oh um let's let's you don't want to go
over there let's go that way hey
what are you doing
I'm just watching some Sky 5 live no no
you have the pool house I already told
you like three times don't come in here
like this you were upstairs you don't
understand the rules you stay in the
pool house if you want to come into the
main house you have to text me 24 hours
ahead of time for permission you cannot
just go when you're upstairs no no dude
get the get out stop leave the drink
why all right do not come back in here
please get out okay go to the pool house
bro stop go dude good talk
okay I guess we're gonna go back in the
pool house yeah yeah you seem a little
on edge
oh okay all right well that was a little
embarrassing we've got the live show on
Friday nobody can know you're here so we
got to just be laying low I was thinking
I was thinking maybe we could go to like
Taco Bell you're gonna blow your cover
we can't go to Taco Bell what about
Chick-fil-A it's the same Pro that does
not fix the problem what about like
Popeyes I wouldn't go to Popeyes you
seem to be not understanding the problem
here I feel like you're probably going
to wander you are very with peace and
love very Swedish looking man there's
like a character creation page yeah yeah
Swede
oh Swede we need to get you disguised
accent what do you mean red flag I don't
have an accent Chick-fil-A what do you
order I don't like your spicy chicken a
spicy what chicken spicy chicken spicy
chicken can you go
you're shushing I need you to shh I need
the lips to shh oh I see and say chicken
one spicy chicken and a baba blast a
baba blast what genre of food is this
chips chips what do you do if someone
says hey would you like to go at Sea and
have a snack I am on a ship and I'm
eating ships I will eat chips on a ship
chips and a chip not chips on a chip now
we got two chips say like this chips how
long have you had this bathroom on a
couple a couple of couple weeks a couple
weeks you didn't even get here till two
days ago chicken sandwich one chicken
sandwich chicken chicken chicken chicken
chicken
let's go uh we're in the thrift store
here we need the disguise what's your
Vibe we think I mean I like something
comfortable what about these
yeah they're kind of Hassan I don't want
to steal if there's a Vibe too much you
might pull it off a little better and
you don't want them to get intimidated
okay yeah what about some like classic
like American Blue Jeans sure yeah what
size are you how about this size
but like what size like the number I
don't know the number did what do you
mean the number I'm just talking about
this they don't have numbers in Sweden I
don't wear pants really I have four pair
up here I have pants in Sweden what is
that you've got there a cheeky little uh
Cowboy thingy here okay so that's good
no that's a Vibe can I get a yeehaw
[Music]
it's got the drip oh yeah bro we got the
drip cover your head cover you put the
hood on no one can see you low profile
low profile okay there's eight Street
fans everywhere look at them all yeah
get inside no pictures no pictures no
pictures
hello there partner I want to order one
of those dangan chickens and a large
Baja Blast yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
Crush
[Applause]
let's put them in the box
box let's box them up all right buddy
come on move move you got to go in the
Box what box you're going in the Box
what the heck is this I need you to get
in there no Ethan's orders Ethan's
orders get in the [__] box or you're
going back to Sweden buddy
even the clean shoes tacos
you look like they're ready to go
bowling are you comfy in there uh can we
get some like snackies or something no
how do I get out dude all right buddy
we'll see you in a few days
you can't just leave me here see ya wait
there it is
so
uh
so you've been here for like a week
right
oh
hello hello
come on Dan yo we good okay you're good
thank you Dan how are weak are we you've
been here for a week about a week
showing you're in my pool house in your
pool house how's it been it's been nice
yeah it's been nice oh yeah yeah just
don't come into the house anymore okay
because it's awkward all right sure
sometimes I'm in there in my underwear
actually Teddy this is serious he told
me this morning he's mad at you because
you haven't played with them yet oh he's
not mad he says just remind love okay
so um listen since Love's here uh we
finally have the opportunity to put him
through all the torments that we in the
studio have survived so come this way
all right
this one's not so much a torment as it
is a pleasure and a joy and a thrill
this store right here I want you to kick
it [__] down
[Applause]
right there dude
kick it down more
all right
easy
hey you know what we've got a third door
let's give the people what they want a b
give the people what they want
the hard problems
no mercy
here it is
didn't open no mercy
what's up you can't open it bro
it's a little embarrassing
okay you want to keep trying or you want
to you don't want to just
I mean you don't want to just give up do
you
all right
yeah I mean
[Applause]
I mean listen technically the door is
still closed
that one's only you know I'm just saying
okay he's he did his best
yeah
uh he doesn't quite have what the
what the with the strength the raw power
that me and love have something wasn't
right with that door no no that one's
fine we didn't no no something wasn't
right
oh you've got almost got there okay
that's close to be fair we may have
built three doors and one of them is
unopenable
I don't remember
um what's with all the beach balls out
there why are you guys bringing beach
balls to our shop that's a good shot
what's with all the beach balls what the
[__] is this
who brought all these
you guys are too you guys know
everything smash that button is that
oh that's just some random dude
with Frenemies merch
[Applause]
smash that button there it is
here he comes
don't let him near those beach balls
guys
[Applause]
guys hit the beach balls to him hit him
to him
get the ball stew the man
[Music]
dad you got full all right Dad you gotta
you got [__] balls man
do something about it
dad
[Applause]
you really gotta do this at my live show
[Music]
is it bad enough you humiliated my whole
life and now this
all right guys
[Applause]
my dad hit that thing like O.J Simpson
all right guys thank you
yay all right guys
[Applause]
all right now that my parents are here
thank you guys dad I I think you got
about two of those beach balls
how you guys doing
yeah
so now that my parents are here
how'd you feel out there doing the beach
balls awesome
I don't think his mic's on but
so we have our first segment coming
we are going to be playing
uh I can't use the name I think we
called it um
uh the the group of closely associated
people in a dispute
[Applause]
[Music]
um oh Jesus
things heavy huh
you guys need help we're gonna win yeah
so we are um
we're gonna set up the couches and we're
playing
oh yeah I can't say it but you guys know
what it is
[Music]
okay
if we're gonna play a game show I'm
talking about Family Feud right you guys
are food
what's another lawsuit
yeah yeah so
if we're gonna play a game show
we're gonna need a game show host
do you guys know any game show hosts
that would want to
would want to be here with us
God if only there was somebody here
if only there was somebody back there
who is ready to come out right now
uh the curtain should go up right right
now here he comes
here he comes right now but yeah put the
curtain up no the curtain's got to go up
wait hold on hold on this isn't
the current goes up right oh here we go
what
do we do about it
oh fine people
nobody needs to hear back people my
friend
foreign
I
saw that yeah we set up a whole prolapse
for you
hit the what my question is is this
coven related
it is it is
it is
happy birthday buddy thank you so much
happy birthday you look beautiful yeah
my teddy fresh
I have to say Howie your National
Treasure I'm a national treasure you are
wow and it's so sweet and there's no
better
no vaginal treasure then shove me out of
Neil's ass oh you know how to do it
buddy did you not know about that well I
did not know about that I just said I
swear we told you I swear we told your
assistant why would you close it that's
such a beautiful yeah yeah how does it
feel to be coming out of the pro-life
you know you have shocked me at the
first I've only done the show Once and I
loved it and you shocked me you showed
me that guy that can actually do it and
I have been practicing
but I promise you my anus is prolapsed
right now
wow wow wow that's how excited I am to
be here let me see oh yeah there's a
little all right there's a little this
is so much better than Chuck E cheese
you know how to throw a party thank you
anyway um um you asked me to come here
to host a game show yes which I've done
before I thought it was going to be deal
or no deal but it's not it's not no we
thought about it but we're like it's too
hard yeah so we put this one together
Family Feud yes so basically your job is
to do like the Steve Harvey thing where
you're like oh believe he said that
wow that's uncanny if my eyes were
closed I think Steve was in the room
yeah you know what I mean but are these
the two teams so the teams are going to
be the ladies versus the guys
okay but that's hila and your mother
these are all the same family a food a
few within a family yeah I thought it
was gonna be you against Trisha I
thought it would be you
maybe even against the ballingers but no
you're gonna keep it
how how do you know this stuff I want
you
I'm a fan then Howie just shout out
Colleen Ballinger I'm a huge fan
that's it wow hey Howie you want to join
the weenie chat with me later
[Applause]
by the way has anyone you I bet shopping
you were shopping at the Century City
Mall I did I love you I love you too
buddy and there's your mom just looking
at her gives me butterflies
all right so here's the game okay we
simplified it I I saw you sent me rules
yeah you asked me to come to rehearsals
I did not I and I I did not ask that
okay I did not ask them to tell me if
I'm right there's gonna be four
questions yes the way we're gonna do it
is we're gonna start with your side okay
I'm gonna ask you a question you have to
see what's up on the board right each
time you get you guess an answer and
it's not up on the board that's a strike
right after three strikes you are out
and Gila Steve gets a chance the man's a
pro he's done it before
at each correct answer would be worth a
hundred dollars or a hundred points oh
there's no money on the line points I've
never
I've never been a game shows it's free
but points but okay but then here's
where it gets interesting
what does the winner get well the winner
it's not what the winner gets it's what
the loser gets
but the winner doesn't get
now you as a comedian have probably
heard of the ACT that's coming up next
Jimmy Lee the Jersey outlaw
thank you
yeah yeah he's pretty big deal but um
the losers have to sit on stage with him
and hype him up
they gotta back him up no matter what
that is fantastic well thanks for having
me thank you start the game you ready
for Family Feud cheers my dude cheers my
dude
cheers my dude okay we're starting with
question number one and we're starting
with Ethan's team uh Ethan are you gonna
take the first do I go down the road yes
okay so the first question is what would
cause the channel to get another strike
Ethan
that's a good question I know you wrote
it I didn't I don't know the answer
somebody wrote yeah
okay well I wanna I'm thinking so you
guys so the question is what would cause
the channel to get another strike okay
bomb threat
bombs which that's when I met you yeah
you were doing that is bomb threat on
the board let's see
[Applause]
oh God three people I'm scared that
that's not number one well it's not
number one there's still seven more
answers to get go ahead dad dad
what would cause
what would cause another strike against
well there's the channel
well there's only seven left
cover but I'm gonna go with covet
misinformation
uh it could be a guess no I know like
you mean like covet can cause a
prolapsed anus exactly something like
that misinformation
misinformation show us misinformation
one strike
your dad is misinformed
all right
okay the question one more time
[Applause]
what would cause the channel to get
another strike you have one strike
against you
harassing Ben Shapiro again
[Music]
Shapiro I'll take that one okay
harassing Ben Shapiro show us harassing
Ben Shapiro
thank you Dan I love you you're a good
man I would never make a death threat
did other people hear that voice or was
that just in my head
what would you know numbers
I just just thought I hope other people
are hearing that and it's not just me
damn okay you got two
all right guys nothing with a CH in it
okay nudity what nudity new nudity
nudity nudity nudity
is there nudity up there
is there show me nudity what
dude what is it we're gonna kill it out
here two strikes Hela get your team
ready what's your team ready one more
strike and you're out what would cause
your channel to get one more strike go
ahead do you know what it is
do you know what it is slurs
slurp
come on they're getting softer and
softer for the record that was my
teammates that wasn't me all right I
don't know show me slur or is hila
getting a chance
okay I want to acknowledge thank you
guys and [__] the two people who
answered slur
and thank you to the 98 other people
answers
you have one more strike
okay you guys aren't watching wait till
you see this replay on YouTube later
you're gonna love it
Ethan it's back to you again back to you
again one more strike they're taking too
long there's no time there's no did
somebody just screaming next segment at
me oh my God okay
I don't I shouldn't have to deal with
live chat at my [__] show
you should be at home typing that [__]
was that you in the Yellow Hat timeout
it was you you [__]
Queen
a segment
listen if there was a next segment I'd
be home so send me
that's my Uber driver yelling next
segment
are we gonna you know what so I'm so
stumped they are taking too long okay
are you making a new rule yeah too long
third strike wait okay I'm gonna say
okay nudity or wait we said hello they
already said nudity
but you said dude okay
I never did that though that's a
conspiracy I don't know what doxing is
violence uh do we see doxy oh my God
show us doxy
there you go three strikes
[Applause]
[Music]
to get another strike
bullying
[Music]
have you ever done anything like that no
yeah pretty much every day the guy in
the yellow hat you just did it to him
yes okay he's bullying me what's your
name dude
what is it
all right so let us know when it's time
to move on okay I was bullied because I
had red hair yeah I'll look to you okay
thanks sour there's bullying right there
let's see if bullying is on the board
show us bullying
one Strike
wow holy [__] okay Dan uh reveal that
right you have to reveal the answers now
let's get it so number seven is
you go backwards that's how they do it
on TV
cabinet
the guy I sold my house to Kavanaugh I
hope you got a good deal did you rip
them off no and the check went through
okay unsurprising number six
no dance
[Applause]
number five
Goblin now
number three
[Applause]
hold on hold on here this is a hint hold
on this is a hint we said nudity Dan
nudity you don't I have a prolapse right
now and I'm not naked show it show it
damn
okay and the number one answer on the
board is
button breaks
43 people that was the biggest one do
you know what they're talking about I
can't put yeah we have a we have an
emergency broadcast button that erases
the last 30 seconds yes and Saul wishes
he had one right now because he wants to
move on smash that button so well are we
good to move on to there or should we
cut this sorry open direct okay thank
you why doesn't he have a mic why
doesn't have a mic you want a mic cello
all right
so now I go to you right now we go to
them and it's question number two okay
question number two Gila your team
what's the worst thing Ethan could
clickbait what is the worst thing that
Ethan could clickbanks Trisha Paytas
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
shouldn't within three seconds of being
on this stage so show us Trisha Pettis
sister-in-law is it on the board no I
told you not to say that
[Applause]
a major reunion she's number eight that
is good
porn what is the worst thing he could
clickbait
[Music]
what did you say what did she says I
didn't hear what your mother said say it
I love when the daughter is afraid to
say what your mother said oh she's Jesus
[Applause]
child pornography from your mother your
mother said child protect that a little
bit using that as click bait no less I
mean
can we unpack that please what are we
talking general you know what that's not
a pack does she know what clickbait is
let's leave it packed up
yes okay wow you think people are gonna
tune in because he says he's touching
babies
yeah you never know you never know it
works on YouTube I thought it was again
but what did you think she does another
wait let me I'll come to you with the
mic you thought what how
[Music]
oh things you let me read the question
again just to make sure it's clear maybe
I don't know what I'm asking what's the
worst thing Ethan could clickbait that
is the worst thing he could ClickBank
all right let's see
he's the only one that understands the
game show us child pornography
thank God thank God if people are just
tuning in right now hey Howie
yes I just want to let you know seoul's
no longer asking to move on and that's
what bothers me
that is concerning Salah are you okay
there's police outside I said move on
until she brought up child pornography
and he went this is good
[__] Howie I want to tell you something
did I just get canceled no but you just
just get sound bited
[Applause]
that is gonna be [__] you uh that's
another sound bite I got you
can we get child pornography
oh that's good we love you oh you love
me I'm gonna need a job
I'm not gonna have a job after this
subscribe to Howie Mandel does stuff
please
because I've lost every other job listen
to my podcast you know last time I was
on yours I got uh 20 000 subscribers
just from being on YouTube
all right where do you go in the middle
of the game where is your teammate your
teammate left where did she go where did
she go
what she's busy she's busy
who leaves the game show oh I'm busy
okay I'm fine people what's the worst
thing Ethan could clickbait so
um somebody dying
somebody dying
he's clicking maybe he died like my
career after he plays the sound bites
yeah yes I love you somebody dying do we
see death on the board death on the
board
[Applause]
oh child no less oh my God
you were close you know it was something
bad happening to the kids you just
didn't know exactly what it was
can you I just want to clean can you
scream child dying no no I can't I will
get you we'll get you again all right
by the way what is the worst thing Ethan
could clickbait all right you you'd come
up with an answer easier if half your
team wasn't busy
where they what
what okay
then quitting let's hear it one more
time for them
Dan quitting Dan quitting do we see Dan
quitting up on the board
damn
[Applause]
or dies
yeah Quince dies what's the difference
man if he leaves the show he's basically
done Friday night is this
cheers my dude
all right
what is the worst thing Ethan could
click bae
oh hi you're not busy anymore where'd
you go where did you go
divorce what divorce are you asking for
one are you answering the question
[Music]
if there was a divorce is divorce up on
the board divorce
thank you
[Applause]
stronger team right here got to give it
to the ladies there's only one strike
right we only have one strike yeah only
one strike and it was your mother's
suggestion
that's what it was what's the worst
thing Ethan could clickbait
[Music]
illness illness
okay illness do we see it's getting
softer and softer illness
ill
cancer
the c word
the c word well they're doing good you
guys are you guys seriously gonna play
that one after I had this I might have
cancer you guys watch the show on no I
probably don't it's fine probably fine
it's just oh
what do we just find out it's just my M
tighters are really high
okay and the white blood cells are
slightly elevated as well slightly are
you okay well my platelets are a little
bit high
and don't get me started on that on the
M tighter
sorry Brothers
[Applause]
the audience going crazy two people
lifted there's my funeral song Yes okay
um so what's the worst thing Ethan could
clickbait the podcast ending
podcast ending not just this segment
the entire podcast going off the air
ending stopping it
the end
through strikes one more strike left and
then your chances end
the dogs
[Music]
I don't know what that means the dogs
the dogs you'll know you'll know
the dark
[Music]
yeah that would be a horrible thing to
do you have no problem you have no
problem talking about child porn child
dying but God forbid the dog should get
sick
oh my God all right so that is still up
there there are two more answers one
more strike
she went do we still have to play
it's like you're here with sale or
whatever
you have so many options you only need
two more
[Music]
the person that says there's so many
options is not saying anything
if it says child dying does that mean
okay go ahead go ahead
using the lawsuit
[Music]
awesome
you have a chance to steal Ethan's team
has a chance to steal okay
they're thinking I can tell they're
thinking
one of the crew members leaving slash
dying which we've established is
basically the same thing yes
what do you say crew member dying or
leaving the show isn't that the exact
same thing if you have cancer you're
gone and if Dan quits he's gone so
you're just saying the same thing again
you just well that's a good strategy
because you know these are up there so
why not repeat one of these
[Music]
understand how you're playing I I
consider Dan to be in a
another no okay something to do with
cabin on that [__] piece of [__] love
ya
and who do we have coming out right now
[Music]
Ryan
do you have an answer cat something
Kavanaugh related I don't know [__]
Kavanaugh something with Kavanaugh being
clickbait
Kavanaugh do we see Kavanaugh on this
board
so they got that win
all right
what yes you won you guys won you guys
won that
we're moving into a round three I love
that you're saying did we win did we win
by round four you guys will understand
how this game is being played it always
takes four rounds okay so now I go to
them reveal the see what we oh number
eight was
Holocaust denial
wow
what the [__] is wrong with you guys
what this one psychotic person is on the
board that's like saying oh you [__]
no that's Mel Gibson is here ladies and
gentlemen Mel Gibson is in the house
all right and number seven lucky seven
is
Hassan
[Music]
wow so yeah Hassan council's crew what
did you you think you said it whatever
they didn't say I did so now I'm
confused it's your turn it's our turn
back to you here is question number
three
name a reason Alphas might think Gila is
divorcing Ethan
name a reason
[Music]
you guys know what it is fat man bad
let's see if it's up there on the board
fat man bad
[Applause]
uh
honestly I didn't see it I didn't
process it was too fast
all right thanks for playing everybody
they they asked me to come to rehearsal
not the guy running that bore
what do you want to do he's fat we'll
continue you know what I do have a there
are bonus questions so let me move on to
another question does that work Dan does
that work I'll go because there was four
there's gonna be a bonus there won't be
a bonus let's move on from that question
Dad let's do this one I didn't see it
you want to play this yeah I didn't see
it okay if you I didn't see
[Music]
yeah I like the category I like the
question wow they all saw it so they're
not guessing
okay they didn't see it it's your show
they saw it all right let's move on
[Music]
I think bonus question I would say Ethan
not living up to his husbandly
responsibilities what
what oh my God so instead of asking you
is that up there
you saw it so Ethan's impotent
that's what you took from that
impotence
Placid let's see the word flaccid
sorry Mom
you are being real generous with them
[Applause]
oh this is ours sure did the apple not
fall far from the trees
okay keep going
name the reason
they might think he is divorcing him
okay okay what's the answer
uh
antidepressants sorry you had to say
that camera yeah that's that's what I
swear I've been given right now
I'm on antidepressants as we speak so me
too me too
what do you take Howie I am I don't know
why that's a bad thing I don't either
that's the reason my wife is staying
with me not yeah me too leaving me but
antidepressants
are antidepressant no that is a strike
you're an idiot
thanks EB thank you I mean that in the
kindest way possible okay keep going why
do you think she might divorce him
go ahead
I gotta go with what I right no
poor
he loses his money is that what you're
saying no money yeah no money you think
she's in this for the cash no it's not
what I'm saying that's what you're
saying
so you think let's see if he goes broke
do we see money up there money gone
money gone
he's not the breadwinner
wow shout out to those two people
wow yeah shout out shout out okay what
you don't have what go ahead he doesn't
go to the gym
because he doesn't go to the gym
okay he didn't go to the gym Gila is
going away
let's see stops working out
stops work is that true
it's what's that yeah wait she's been
working out I don't understand that uh
yeah that's what they do say that they
say people say they say she's been
working out therefore she's gonna leave
me she's been working out and he hasn't
oh because he doesn't go to the gym
Waits what your mother says that you're
cheating
okay
do we give it to him
wait if wait if you think if you think
that they should get it give me Applause
okay okay if you think they shouldn't
get it give me Applause
[Applause]
so you don't get it that's a strike
tough crowd that's a strike you gotta go
with the eyes
so that is okay so how about the next
answer is she's been working out yeah
all right show me
yes
[Applause]
okay all right and one and another
answer how many strikes do you have I am
so [__] confused do you think you
think if I would have showed up at
rehearsal it would go any smoother no no
okay not on the 8th Street podcast what
everyone
they're thinking height is height
okay all right we got something because
Ethan is too blue pill to what blue
pilled blue pilled blue pill is that
like Viagra like yeah little blue pill
over four hours is that what you're
saying I don't know what you're saying
is that what he said just Just go with
it
I feel like I'm working in another
country I don't speak the language yeah
I'm sorry this is but these are going to
be blue pills Bluefield means I'm like a
[Music]
blue pill do we see blue pill
three strikes you get a chance to steal
you get a chance to steal okay so what
is your answer
name a reason that you might be
divorcing him
um because I've been posting hot photos
[Applause]
you think that's up there
[Music]
and they get that right yeah they get it
that's they're so far ahead there is no
catching up right okay now we're going
to round three the final round okay I'm
gonna tell you number seven is
ugly you leave him because you think
he's ugly he's adorable
number six is small hands
uh you guys are gross to me good man
yeah but those small hands make his
penis look huge
number three is
why is that why is that bad why is that
bad
what the [__] is wrong with you people
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay is it one more question is
that it or did we finish the ladies go
next but no it seems like they are gonna
win it seems like they're gonna win they
can't even catch up
do they want to play it yeah let's see
what it is
it's not up to me uh so so solo
[Applause]
look what they've done what is happening
all right
what a crack team you put together here
you're really the best only the best yes
hey Dan that's got to be someone for
some reason they brought out three
podiums nobody used
who's ever running the board focus on
the prolapse focus on the prolapse I
know but I I think the game's over right
which means it's my let's read tomorrow
let's let's read them off at least enjoy
the question the questions yeah okay
uh who could Ethan beat in a Creator
Clash fight
[Music]
Kavanaugh is he creator
uh he he wishes he was Jimmy Lee
Philip DeFranco
quartering
Boogie or Boogie keemstar
Bobby Lee
or Oliver tree number one
you want to hear the bonus question
here's the bonus question what's
something that even even imagine this
Howie Mandel would find shocking
what is something that even I would find
shocking remember I just came to you
through an ass so what would I
fine shocking you guys wanna you guys
let's all play it together we'll go one
answer here one answer there I think
it's got to be well I gotta put out the
prolapse right I mean listen you were
shocked by it you did shot yeah you were
that guy that guy he has a name how it
people I don't I don't remember I'm
trying to blank it out of my mind show
me bro
I said uh if you want to look them up
later that FF stands for fist [__]
yes he's the best in the game he is the
best ever we hired him for my daughter's
birthday party
yeah perfect well she doesn't like
clowns does he do bar mitzvahs what
about Mitzvah what a great that would be
a wouldn't that be a great that's a
Mitzvah that's uh instead of the candle
lighting ceremony hunger FF all right
what would shock me ladies what would
shock me no
[Applause]
well
go ahead what are you saying
oh no go ahead um okay Ethan clogging
the toilet
maybe it's more shocking Egan Ethan
clogging the toilet a turn a float a
dookie
this is this one's tough maybe you want
to give an answer what would shock me
yeah oh um I'll tell you yeah everybody
in this room coming forward and touching
me yes yep touched by strangers being
touched by strangers is being touched up
there
germs they get it do I know me do I know
me who else go ahead what are you gonna
say here this would never happen of
course but somehow you got fired from
AGT I think you're witnessing it tonight
sir
I don't know how it would be shocked if
you told me that an hour ago 15 minutes
after he captured my sound bite not so
shocking you know what would be shocking
if tomorrow I find out I'm still working
on AGT
losing AGT
if I read that out loud I will be
I'm not gonna read that out loud
scream it please Howie because that's
how people refer to me
when you go who's that
I'm not gonna read it [__] you
they the people want you to scream Simon
Cowell's [__] say [__] you then read
that
um go ahead let's let's I think let's
just throw them up this is gonna be hard
yeah let's just throw them up okay go
ahead eight number eight is uh murder
[Applause]
pesto [__]
Heights
sounding I don't know what sounding is
there it is okay well first of all I
can't thank you enough for having me
buddy is it okay happy birthday yes
you're gonna come on you're gonna come
on Howie Mandel does stuff both of you
and
I haven't been told but whatever you
need me to do I'll do it stick around
for one sec because there's one more
thing we've prepared for you okay but
you guys will come on mine right you'll
come on Halloween stuff yeah and you
guys will subscribe Howie Mandel does
stuff
this man he's always plugging and we
love it you did good okay so where do I
go good job everybody obviously the guys
the guys lost hold on hold on we're not
done we're not done you want to stay
right here just one more thing okay okay
so um
how do you guys feel about losing that
one uh it's gonna be rough for you guys
and not me
oh this is the loser okay so since we
have you here right
and why not take advantage of me yes we
have the Giants you know sometimes I get
paid double what I'm getting paid
tonight I'll double it zeros
triple it if you want
so we have the prolapse everybody's
talking about the pro Labs Neil is in
the crowd hey Neil dude is there a Neil
there there is a Neil okay
you thought he was taking a bow how many
inches is your prolapse
seven that's respectable eight wow
all right so um so okay guys this is the
part of the show which I promised was
gonna happen
thank you wow you okay
we have
the infamous prolapse video
now I don't believe you've seen this
Howie
you have only seen a real-life prolapse
which is arguably maybe more shocking
but no it's not more shocking than this
video
okay now so here's what but before I do
that because I
I don't know if it's legal
so I brought out my attorney
[Applause]
to counsel me
yeah it's the one and only
I may I may I mean
so you excited Howie we're gonna watch
this together yeah I'm gonna watch it
car
oh Howie we need the mic though we need
the mic don't steal the mic let's go
let's go
let's go all right so David thank you
for being here how's business
I don't think his mic is on by the way
really good
[Music]
business is really good business is
really good thank God thank God for
the people
all the village of Gotham let's go
okay so the reason I brought you here is
for your I need your counsel all right
so you've seen the video so you know
what I'm talking about I can forget
about it yeah yeah about it okay so last
time we did a live show David was the
only one to view the prolapse video okay
now the last show was all ages
that was a mistake
this show is 18 plus
thank you
so only adults in the audience
no there's no [__] kids in here right
okay if you see a child
they
you check their IDs
they didn't check your ID they check you
oh no wait oh [__] I don't know I think
that but that might actually be a
problem I don't know okay but that might
be a problem did they check your guys's
IDs
[Applause]
oh god
oh that that could be a problem for me
give me give it are you acting like you
care I do care about your Council go
ahead
all right look
as an attorney
I must
I cannot engage in conduct that is
Unbecoming of an attorney I'm not asking
you to prolapse
now
the problem is that whether it's legal
or not I'd be engaging in conduct that's
on becoming of an attorney by telling
you to show it to all these David have
you seen your Tick Tock let's go
Mr Jones alive
this is really really [__] up and I
can cuss because you guys are above 18.
but you want to show it anyway don't you
uh you don't I do I do I have to you've
come too far you don't you don't leave
listen to your attorneys anyway so what
is your counsel ultimately don't do it
look
you can't even advise me it's so [__]
up I I can't even advise you but I I
just want to say something to to the
guests because you guys have been so
good to me and I love you so much and
I saw this video
all right so just because I love you I'm
gonna give you an advisement all right
viewer discretion is highly highly
highly advised
this video is very very very [__] up
well depends well let's not let's not
paint you know it's hunger FF boy he's
the best at what he does
Flint I mean [__] that one man's
prolapse is another man's treasure
but given your reaction I think you're
all gonna like it so okay so here's what
we're gonna do you've been warned so if
somebody sues me you you'll represent me
and I'll be representing Ethan so be
careful don't even think about it thank
you
oh
all right so here's what we're gonna do
and I'm being dead serious now this is
the long-awaited group viewing of the
legendary prolapse video
now here's what I want to say
this video is about uh
how long's the video it's like a two
minutes
[Music]
mom I want you to look specifically
sound give me some kind of like romantic
kind of something get us in the mood
I like this it reminds me of two girls
one cup
okay so that's the vibe I'm going for if
you do not want if you do not want to
watch two men's prolapses touch
and at the center
create these singularity
that close your eyes or look away while
we do this
[Music]
if you do not want to see a man prolapse
10 inches out and another one hook it
with his finger
you will you please close your eyes or
look away
I saw a person running
I saw a person running out yeah someone
left so I mean listen you cannot see
this
this is Pandora's prolapse if you would
there's no putting it back in the anus
that might be true actually
[Music]
all right so
okay
so cue it up
the first five seconds is just and then
we're gonna do we're gonna turn on the
audience lighting so we can get a crowd
reaction
there it is
there they are the beautiful people
[Applause]
faces
yes oh oh we've got the Howie prolapse
uh stained glass
yo can you can you bring it up
okay fair enough do you see Martin
oh Martin's here what the [__]
wait Martin what are you doing here
the water Smalley is here
hello everybody cheers
little flavored water today for me it's
a polana but it's another water come on
it's great it's great
so I had two guests early at my
restaurant and they said like hey I'm
going to the H3 podcast and they're like
what they're doing a live podcast so I I
texted Olivia please don't show it to me
huh don't show it to me don't even think
about it Ethan
hopefully you didn't buy it
out of pure life look at this horrified
water my friend
it says healthy hydration on it so okay
so
okay well Martin is here uh are you
ready to view this
you're gonna watch it
Martin is here to assess the purity of
the prolapse
foreign
nice to see you I didn't expect that
love Martin
okay so cue it up
the first three seconds is just a black
screen okay
it's ready to go it's happening
okay so when the Music Stops you'll you
those who do not want to view this
can open your eyes
and once again
if you do not want to see a man put
a prolapse the size of a watermelon in
his mouth
you will want to close your eyes
or look away
and if you think what I'm saying is bad
it's worse
okay here it is so with all that being
said
my beautiful fans
you know
in a sense this is educational
I mean when do you get to visually see a
colonoscopy happen
are you still screaming [__] Raul
[Music]
um
18 plus
[Laughter]
[Music]
David's worried for me
I mean what what what's Dumber doing
this or or driving drunk and then
crashing running
which is worse
[Music]
well
one of them you really plan for in
advance and the other one kind of just
happens right there and there oh my God
you're not helping me that sounds bad
sometimes you're unaware okay you gotta
show the laughs you know what I mean
it's what you know what
I would do so much for a laugh
it's educational it's educational you
guys
and and hunger FF he's a friend of the
show and it's art he's doing art
all right everybody who doesn't want to
watch look the [__] away
close your eyes Dan roll the goddamn
[__] video
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right
[Applause]
yes
oh my God
[Applause]
that's hunger right there friend of the
show
[Applause]
all right
we're done
Standing Ovation for Hunger
we are admiring his his art
his craft
also I'm happy to to uh announce that
his
his anus does look clean no uh no tumors
or anything
it was way worse than you guys thought
right
thank you for that and by the way my
favorite part
read when it cuts to them going prolapse
to prolapse and he's like there's a dude
just kind of mixing it up
I like the moisture in it
oh what happened
what happened
hold on one sec
[Applause]
uh hold on one sec guys just a little
bit of a spill
are you okay
she need a water
we get our water some
Martin you have water on you
Martin's going no no the arrowhead
oh no not the pure
I know yeah
[Music]
it's just oh I don't think she knows
where she is right now
she had a few too many okay
got a water
yeah oh my God
all right where were we oh yeah the
prolapse
um wild man
I can't wait to see the shot of
everybody's reaction
it was good it was good yeah it was good
it's so educational I videotaped you the
whole time because I've never seen you
so happy ever
you know this was a moment in the making
for so long oh my God I'm so happy for
you
and guys so I know how important this is
to you it's powerful
[Music]
the dude on the right prolapsing that
was our boy hunger so
he is really good at what he does
all right guys
if you thought that was offensive wait
for our Nest segment
[Applause]
there is a man
there is a myth
there is a legend a man who comes out of
New Jersey
he's got
an incredible hairline
[Applause]
and actually I owe this to him because
he did such a good job on the uh
on the video yeah so Jimmy Lee where are
you let's get you out here man
come on outlaw
bring out the outlaw
Jimmy uh
every minute now
Jimmy Lee
shimmy Lee the Jersey outlaw
[Music]
Jersey outlaw
how about that and then where's the
losing reception for the Jersey Outlaw
Jim England
how about a steady Ovation I came all
the way in come on guys let's hear it
wow what a surprise
a standing ovation now
uh Jimmy you've prepared a set for us
what's that you prepared a set for us
yes I did and then I have some roasting
I would like to do okay just can you
face forward and just can we get a shot
at the airline yes
somebody zoom in on that
it's important all right zoom in on the
airplane oh they can see it yeah here
just put your head down a little bit
yeah there you go you can see it what do
you guys think of the hairline
[Applause]
and if you like the hairline let me hear
you say yay
yeah okay where are the losing um the
losing uh Team these illusions
of Me no wow I wasn't there
technically the the boys so here's what
I want to do uh Amy this outfit was a
lot cooler like a minute ago oh yes I
warned him that's why I didn't wear
their jacket
you don't wear [__] leather jackets
AJ's got my jacket guys sit Christy
cross here
I need Chrissy cross yeah and then who
else cam come on yeah baby let's go a b
your camel's blocking the aisle whoa
okay
[Applause]
oh did you real you brought out the
camel jokes already he told me to do it
oh brother who's that cam
do you know that cam caught a
handicapped guy trying to park in one
hour spots he kicked his ass out let's
hear it for cam
all right and
um so before I'm gonna hand the reins
over to you in one sec so there's a
little bit of a special angle to um this
we brought out some very soft
fruits okay Tomatoes if I mess up and
lots of them that you guys well you guys
will pass out we bought like a thousand
of them from China
oh geez yeah you guys could just throw
him
save me oh boy Jimmy we we agreed upon
this beforehand I know this is just a
nice polite way if Jimmy tells a joke
that maybe uses a little offensive uh oh
you can express your thoughts with a
soft lovely tomato
don't do it and if you could just
lovingly throw it up with all the tender
Grace in the world
can I could I just say real quick
cam was saying this feels like a hostage
video what's that I feel I feel like
this is a hostage video right here a
hostage video Yeah Isis
jokes yeah the guy outside they had
fudge sickles and water ice and the guy
screaming Isis Isis I said don't scream
Isis people get they get funny okay
so guys I wanted to apologize
I was a little bit late I was at Ethan's
house in his garage loosening the brakes
on his car
okay all right don't throw any Tomatoes
yet wait till I do two jokes and then
you can you can do it but I want to tell
you guys I was taking a shower blow dry
in my hair moose in it gel in it and
then and then it dawned on me who looks
down there anyway you know what I mean
oh hey oh come on tomorrow's a special
day yes but uh I love that Martin's just
here participating in the show who is
that just 100 genuinely Martin is
throwing Tomatoes into the audience now
don't throw him up here so I guys I want
to tell you
over I set it up and then you go all
right all right we legit did buy like a
thousand tomatoes so
hello we got him from China legitimately
Alibaba wait a minute your son's a [__]
that was for the camel one that was the
camel
work with me
all right you you guys keep keep handing
them out and all right Jimmy we you have
so here's the deal you have 20 minutes
yes including the crowd work okay okay
yes sir so and and occasionally I'll be
checking in with the guys to get a temp
check okay on the jokes they're gonna
defend you okay they must all right are
we ready
we got it do we have a timer so before
we start our set I want to tell you guys
that tomorrow Saturday we're filming our
Live Comedy television show for 10 hours
tomorrow in Hollywood Beverly Hills
pinks hot dogs so if you guys are around
come on and stop down uh and pinks is a
big stop we'll be there around lunch so
come on down and uh you'll get on
television tomorrow what are you talking
about what is happening my comedy TV
show tomorrow we're filming it I took a
swing of water and he's I don't know
what's happening all right so guys let
me tell you about my comedy career okay
let me tell you how good I'm doing I'm
doing so good I'm the only one that
actually knows about my show you see the
new the New York Times gave me two
thumbs down
and the people in Hollywood they gave me
one finger up okay it's like
the mayor the mayor listen to this the
mayor of Las Vegas sent me a very nice
letter they said so happy you're in
Hollywood to give you an idea how good
I'm doing I'm not I'm not a who too hey
hey
hey I'm not a who's who it's like a who
cares but I do want to tell you guys
something I signed a five-year deal last
week with the Win Casino in Las Vegas
Nevada how about that guys
how about that and guess what guys now
we're waiting for them to sign
how about that how about that and when
I'm in Las Vegas honey I sign 100
autographs a day no one takes them but I
sign them anywhere
and I got people
Porter line up to see me they call those
law
s look you see that's pretty much how
their career is going I did a
one-nighter in Vegas two weeks ago she
was lovely
and the cool thing about going to Las
Vegas is if you don't bring a girl they
send one right up you can ask Zach
Bernstein he'll tell you all about that
I know nothing
the tomatoes
wait a minute now guys take a break take
the take a Viagra honey will you please
my God so let me tell you let me tell
you
holy moly let me tell you about my wife
I don't know if you guys know I'm
married
and my wife my wife is Chinese once in a
while she's on her knees you know about
that oh
[Applause]
now wait a minute I got another oh
wait a minute
lovingly now wait a minute I'm coming on
this side she's from the she's from
Hawaii she's from the island of I like a
Dickie
whoa hey I'm going back up hey he's fast
he's fast hey hey I found out she's
faking orgasm Zach told me last night oh
she wants to have sex in the backseat of
the car now she wants me to drive sit
the hell down your son's a [__]
I hope you jump on your bike and there's
no seat you German rat bastard and get
rid of the armband
I'm gonna put the rifle put the rifle
down my God stop with the tomatoes
you're killing me I just said stop
will you stop
my God I can't even do my set shut the
hell down you pain in the ass my God
what are you doing
you looking for a buffet oh my God look
at the size of this one oh my God
wait a minute I'm not done
my God what did you eat for dinner
will you stop wait a minute the Jersey
outlaw
okay wait wait wait now hope shut the
hell down you're right bastard Jimmy
we'll we'll give you more time it's a
nice shirt stand up young fella this guy
right here stand up
at times the circus goes sure you want
to get closer Jimmy you want to work you
want to work this guy's gonna work the
cotton candy machine
and look at this guy stand up
you want a banana
my God he looks like a gorilla Jesus
Christ
my God
what
[Music]
what's your name
you got something on under your chin oh
it's your other chin stop throwing
tomatoes
with you it's not
ah how you guys doing over here thank
you nobody's throwing Tomatoes up how
you doing big guy
how you doing I took you into the
7-Eleven you didn't come out till 6 10.
I know you you son of a [__] when you
sweat you sweat marinara sauce will you
stop growing a goddamn Tomatoes my God
you guys are killing me
I'm coming back up here all right Jimmy
wait let's reset let's reset well I have
jokes I'll give you more time I'll give
you more time
oh you're gonna roast me no I have one
joke okay cool okay
I'll give you more time I just want to
make sure I gotta say I appreciate the
audience they really took the Tomato
task the heart in that they're killing
me when you brought up the Fat Joe they
unloaded on you they definitely they
bled you guys blitzcrigged me on the fat
jokes
my God how you doing sir
oh now we got that how you doing Lock
and Load guys how long have you been
like that since the accident look at
this guy on the end looks like I busted
you on an angle
my God how you doing buddy how you doing
you can't get a convertible like me you
can't wear a convertible like me over
there the ball-headed guy he got with
the fake beard snap out of it take a
Viagra my God all right I got some jokes
about h3h3 you guys want to hear them
now we're talking
[Applause]
these are all facts Dan do you guys know
Dan the hater
[Applause]
Dan
gets hundreds of fan mail every week
from bullheaded women let's hear it for
Dan right now stop with the tomatoes
did you know did you guys know Ian it
takes him an hour and a half to watch 60
minutes
true story cam
cam caught a handicap guy trying to park
him on our spots he kicked his ass out
what do you think about it yeah
well because you didn't laugh the first
time you're right bastard snap out of it
you're right bastard
and did you know that Zach went to a
meeting for premature ejaculators he
went he came early but he was there
but he came early but he was there
do you know what I told AB make up with
the Jews I'll get them
get them stop with the tomatoes oh come
on Jimmy
did you know Olivia told me something
very interesting
so stop throwing the tomatoes
you fat bastard stop oh my God oh my God
Jesus Christ so fine I know you're
trying to lose weight but every time you
go jogging you run into restaurants sit
the hell down
that one was perfect did you know did
you guys know what Olivia told me today
she said if you're gonna have sex with
an animal do it with a horse and this
way you have a ride home how about
[Applause]
and did you know that Lena told me
something interesting she said to you
sit the hell down you rat bastard
she told me that she told me that the
Italians invented the toilet seat but
the Jews were smart enough to put a hole
in the middle
all right now check her papers
wait what was that one can you expand
pack that one Sam I don't know if you
know Sam cooks for the show
but she's a lousy chef
but you tell her because I want to come
back on the show
I told Sam
tomatoes
Jimmy's final back
it's chaos Jimmy's fighting back
Martin's on stage
[Applause]
oh my God what your fat son's a [__]
oh my God now you're against me you were
my juke token
come on God this is chaos
I didn't expect you to fight back that I
like I didn't hell I didn't finish
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't I didn't finish the h3h3 jokes
you know that guys pipe down take a
Viagra
did you know
stop did you know
did you know that Hill is so rich when
she spits Zach catches it true story
true story
nasty do you know that Ethan is cheap he
buys generic rubbers because he's a
cheap [__]
but Ethan won't go to jail because he
eats locks
okay correct
I know what I said hey oh yours weren't
funny either pal
okay what's your name Osama been
drinking
he's in crunch
damn you fat [__]
[Applause]
oh man he had enough take a picture stop
it all right I think we're nearly 20
minutes here guys guys
did you like the show let me hear you
say yay
did you like seeing the Jersey Outlaw
tonight let me hear you say yeah
did you like the jokes about the fat
girl in the front let me hear you say
yay no no she said yes
do you want the church Jimmy come here
all right I think we're good all right
let's deep breathe
hello back
[Applause]
all right let's let's debrief we're
debriefing according to the big boss
it's a tough crowd will you you you did
this you didn't have to do this you
for the planned event I
it was kind it was pretty fun
I went it was all her fault this one
this one you guys have real beef here
this one right here
no you
you look at the size of this bro
[Music]
Rick
oh my God what do you eat for breakfast
dinner
boy Jimmy I love you Jimmy these are
called jokes sir I'm a comedian well
that's debatable according to me all
right Jimmy Jimmy hold on hold on hold
on
here she does a question for you what do
you got love
if they're jokes why aren't they funny
nope
can answer that
I can't no I
like do you want to see something really
funny because I'll tell you what you got
to do
you'll get naked look in the mirror
that's funny
[Music]
oh my God they're called jokes
what do you want to do here
what do you want to do sorry Jimmy I
[Applause]
because he's not gonna stop
guys yeah it's just kill his mine and
it's a character I'm trying to bring
this show back come on he doesn't stop
[Applause]
now I feel sad but you do what nobody
likes you
you know I love you you know
no no you're going to throw the water on
me there I know that oh no I don't want
that yeah
yeah so and guys okay okay Dad wait wait
wait stop I do comedy to laugh at
ourselves and have fun I don't have a
mean bone in my body and that's the kind
of Comedy I do when I do it with a
little fomo guys guys he's history on it
patriotic person look at his shirt there
it is
there it is so guys do me a favor and
show The Jersey out a little up because
I could jump off the building I'm a
little sad right now the Jersey Outlaw's
a little sad all right Dad kill his mic
for Christ's sake
all right
Dan what's going on back there
all right I got I got to bring this show
back on the rails thank you Jimmy guys
give it up for Jimmy
he Jimmy uh listen he's histrionic
we've tried
but he's he is a good man Jimmy come
here
you're a good man good sport
[Music]
all right Jimmy Lee everybody
the one and only Jersey outlaw
one and only
I gotta say the Tomato aspect was
pretty wild
I mean there was a moment when he took
up the fat joke and y'all just like
[__] unloaded it was like Gulf War up
in this [__] I feel like they should do
that in a stand-up comedy places right
just get that that's perfect for
stand-ups just give the audience
tomatoes
great
all right now that the tomatoes have
been introduced to the audience we're
all Target
all right so guys
um we are coming up on our next
segment it is as you know
my birthday almost
thank you thank you guys
I will be turning
38 38.
30 no
four
[Music]
38 guys come on this is not funny
anymore
it's not funny
okay but because it's almost my 38th
birthday we have prepared everybody on
the stage uh has prepared a special
birthday
has prepared a special birthday present
for me and so
um if we're ready let's start bringing
out the presents yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for Ian happy birthday
you need help you got it yes yes
the big day Ian is going to be leading
us
through this magical journey
uh you know what let's kick things off
real strong here
[Applause]
[Music]
what'd you say
mail for Sam yes yes
uh this is from Donna now Donna hiked
this gift up a lot
wait what's wrong Mom
this isn't it
what happened I'm gonna open it that's
the gift
these nuts
hell yeah
all right I'm I'm gonna open it okay go
ahead
Pizza shaped
what should I like
[Applause]
it's a pooper scooper
is there a message behind this gift well
you know whenever we go to the house on
the lawn Shredder and Alfredo have left
their presents that is not true do not
defame my dogs
I denounced that
go ahead mom you could well I mean I I I
uh
you know I just thought that would help
with you know with your dog [__] my dog
[__] in your house no no no no no
okay well what a thoughtful gift Mom
this is so nice
thank you mom what a special special
present for myself this was for clogging
the toilet she's just scooping the [__]
out that's it that's it idea all right
we gotta shovel this out of here
[Music]
all right thank you Mom
very touching
so that one is from cam I believe right
is that that's me oh
Cameron hi everybody thoughtful come on
I know what this is I don't think are
these all [__] related items it is
variations on a theme right now but
all right
[Music]
there you go
[Applause]
thank you
it says world's best boss yeah it's been
it's been well established at this point
that you're the Michael Scott of our uh
of our operation here and he has a uh
mug that says world's best boss so I
figured I'd give you something similar
but with more utility for your brand
thank you man that's so thoughtful of
course anytime Happy Birthday Happy 43rd
that me that makes me feel special 43
more
I feel so loved with the pooper scooper
and the toilet plunger
um most bosses they get like a mug or a
t-shirt or something right this is real
[__] thank you Cameron literally
oh this is the good ones I like these
ones where they suck it up
and then the [__] gets stuck in it and
you have to drain it back in the toilet
nothing but the best for the world's
best boss beautiful
this one is
[Music]
got it right there okay Lena's a good
gift buyer I have to say oh Lena did you
get those bubble Blasters for the boys
oh my God that was such a great present
they love those thank you I got it on
Teddy's birthday but I knew I had to get
two one yeah that was smart
yeah yeah
[Applause]
they're definitely at the at the stage
where they each need it or it's War yeah
but that was great so let's see
hopefully she got me a Bubble Blaster
too
we have oh is this a like a camel uh
[Applause]
back
finally take that height
wait what is it a hiking backpack
just in case you decide to take up Billy
on that invite so it's good for hiking
yeah yeah this will get a lot of use
thank you
[Laughter]
[__] Philip DeFranco
yeah do we love Philly yeah yeah yes
okay so I've got a Camelback thank you
so much okay and then there's more
um
oh my God
is it pants
even better even better than that they
are pants that transform into shorts
shaking my pants
[Applause]
I [__] my pants today
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
again
yeah
I got one more
[Music]
thank you Lena Donna as as his mother
that's for the uh security guard enjoy
those maybe you can tell me what's his
problem what did you do to him as a
child
with long fans he went to Washington DC
and it was really cold out yeah he wore
shorts yeah
you did he has more in long pants since
he was I don't know 15. pants is
[__] I mean what the [__]
I live in Los Angeles I mean what's a
little about cold weather
it's a conspiracy believe in it all
right what's next all right the next one
is from Olivia oh oh Olivia hello
yeah yeah
give it up for the PowerPoint Queen
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so for your birthday I wanted to
get you something that I know
you don't normally dip your toe into but
I think you would love to and it's
the hot girls take care of ourselves
basket
foreign
yeah
all right all right let's see what's in
here I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a whole Fun Pack we got the
Tranquility with lavender and chamomile
to ease into sleep
essential oils thank you thank you lots
of lots of little trinkets in that
basket for you to take care of yourself
and then there's one one surprise a
blankie yeah very soft
the most soft I'm having a spa day yeah
kind people are my kind of people am I
right
am I right
people are actually not my kind of
people to be honest I don't associate
that that well with them a book The
Weekly self-care project
have you read this I actually have no I
haven't
did uh I like page through it you know
it looks beautiful I think I think that
yeah 30 off too it's obviously very
popular hey we can all use some
self-care let's see take the time to
care for yourself
amid the hustle the hurry and the Havoc
slowing down to care for yourself may
feel impossible it is so important
though
but what if self-care stopped being seen
as an indulgent or external
it's already that became a meaningful
person
okay come on thank you so we got the
self-help book
and we got the year more that's a little
like diffusion oil to help you sleep
more oils we love oils yes
we got like some face masks lavender
face masks strawberry face mask chill
out face mask absolutely Ela feel free
to take some absolutely
um that's my decision that is up to you
that is up
and slippers yeah little sweet slippers
slippers you guys
they have little grippers on the bottom
so you won't slip cute they fit
yes
are they so cozy I feel like Cinderella
yeah you look like look lindarella
before the ball okay and
a basket a coupon for one free trip all
expenses paid for
Ayahuasca cult Retreat yes
[Applause]
just say the word and we're going oh
we're going together yes whenever you
want to cash that in we're going okay
yeah that's very special
should I use this during my Ayahuasca
trip or no 100 let's pack it all I'm
gonna puke and [__] all over this stuff
yep yep yep it's girl it's your
self-care
whatever you need girl
oh yes girl hey girl yes girlies where
my girlies at
yes
[Music]
oh my mom's throwing up the BTS we love
BTS
I [__] love BTS man
I love those guys and also when there's
multiple groups of both genders like
black pink is women beautiful talented
women they are and then BTS is they're
those are the one with the men in it and
they're very talented they have that
song butter that I love
hi BTS yeah
yeah please don't
and if you're yeah just please don't
mention me to other people just please
keep me out of it whatever BTS I love
them whatever yes
[Applause]
baby I don't I don't know what the deal
is with this one there's just a guy
just said you wanna come out guy
there's just a guy here I don't know
what the deal is this is a guy hi this
is AVS uh yeah so that's my brother
um
yeah he looks like you hi
you're always talking about how helpful
I am you know you appreciate my work
ethic but I can't go home with you but
now you have another version of me
basically you can take home help you
around the house whatever you need he's
there for you are you my slave
okay I always wanted a slave
I'll tell you what I'll be your George
Washington I'll be your daddy Georgie
you guys know slavery was actually very
embellished
just kidding not my words button button
button literally
oh yeah button
okay so you're gonna be my slave no I
was thinking more like adopt him or
something like the animatilda you want
me to adopt him
it sounds better than slave I mean
servant uh
uh so is that can we do slave driving
can you baby
what's your child experience do you have
children with children
no but I can't
he's on a refund on this
okay what are you good at
um taking care of kids
[Music]
this guy's blowing it
thank you yeah
tell him what you need him to do he'll
do it thank you and what was your name
it's Jeff now
it's Ethan Jr you're junior now
hmm
I own a person
all right who's next stay right here
don't move
all right this is from Ela oh oh my
beautiful wife Eva what did you get me
oh my gosh I think you're gonna love it
really
oh you know me so well it's prolapse red
yo platform Crocs
the slippers are coming off
oh my God I'm so [__] tall right now
[Applause]
for guys yeah holy [__] let's go
AB stand up I knew you're gonna come
straight stand up
sucks to be short
short King though we love short Kings
thank you
[Applause]
hey dude okay if you're gonna be my
slave you're gonna have to laugh harder
than that
good job thank you we'll work on that
aren't they kind of fire dude these are
unironically insane
wait why do they sell these
like who would actually who's walking
around with like a three look at the
[__] it's like four inches
it's just from Croc's website
it's at the store yeah oh God Crocs is
really Innovative man those guys know
what they're doing
[Music]
yes
hi yeah thank you for that that was
really good
um okay thank you Eli I mean I do love
these yay laughs
[Applause]
let's go
that's how much I love you guys I just
showed you my [__] balls
usually you got to pay more than that
whatever you're okay who's next all
right the next one is from Zach Lewis
live at the Troubadour Roxy soda bar
missing any
can you open this please
so I know you always talking about my
guest list right
hold on just for the record we pushed it
on the guest list we had 40 people on
our guest list
[Applause]
so I got you exact
ly very special One of a Kind one of a
kind and it looks like my other [__] got
bent below it
um
well Dan do we have a
here it is yes your very own Zach Lewis
headshot I can't believe it a signed
headshot
look at that sexy beast look at him wow
yeah
and finally you're always talking about
the guest list Ethan I got two tickets
for the gasoline
slit to you my friend
can you help me put this shirt on please
help me I put this shirt on me
by the way that QR code goes to my group
let's go
skinny King skinny King skinny Legend
over here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you look stunning doll face
thank you so much he's working out he's
pretty good leaving he's pretty good
yeah he's great
oh
wait so why is it two tickets for Ethan
for Ethan you know Ethan Hilo you know
whatever you want I can bring a guest
yeah I wonder who I'll bring you're on
the guest list you know for the San
Diego show you know yeah okay there it
is guys happy birthday August 19th 8 P.M
August 17th
19th August 17th 19th thank you sir it's
very very happy what a nice gift for me
happy birthday definitely not for you
thank you
from Love
I it says from love for Ethan and I was
like I don't remember giving myself a
present right with love slightly
confusing for Ethan all right love
so I've been hanging out a lot at your
house lately as you know
um so
I've captured some moment with us you'll
remember them when you see them of
course
um and you know I'd like you to place
these around your house maybe
um and you you'll of course remember all
these moments
um
I don't remember this oh
well that's when oh do you that was uh
I am not putting these
Indonesia Sunday
I like the original way better too
come on dude I don't this Photoshop
no you photoshopped these dude what do
you mean that's that's the last week
which was that one I know for a fact you
remember
that one you remember for sure
that's right outside your house dude out
my our house
[Music]
why not happy birthday thank you
this is great thank you such a
thoughtful gifts right no worries
who's next hold on let me get my scepter
I feel like a king today
this is from me
so we're halfway to fix Miss
not quite there but
[Applause]
[Music]
WWE one person one give it up for Ian
first
[Applause]
yeah
pretty good pretty good wow
you know the last time I was here I saw
Ariana Grande here
typically the same person I am Ariana
right now I'm can I hear a whistle
whistle
[Applause]
that's great they were good yeah yeah
fantastic you nailed it all right I'm
gonna open it okay so this this is a
find you know I'm I'm proud of myself
for this this is cursed it's not cursed
it's the opposite I thought there was no
such thing as cursed stuff it's very
blessed okay chill Zach
[Laughter]
yeah
very careful this is a artifact
yeah yeah yeah
just what I wanted
a dollar in the woods keemstar memorably
memorabilia vinyl
now look
that's signed it's science that is
signed wait are you serious that is real
this is cursed oh my God
this is bad energy what 25 or best
offers
oh my God yes there are 200 of those so
that's about like that's like 18 more
rare than a Beau Blackstone
so he's legit selling selling these huh
oh yeah he looks so gay okay
so you want you hang that by Love's
pictures that's a beautiful wall thank
you yeah that's fantastic this is very
special and I'm I'm so happy to support
him that makes sense
okay so Sam uh is the second of last she
cooked something up for you
oh oh Sam Cooked me something
what's a birthday without a case right
[Applause]
all right what Abomination is in this
thing
what this is
oh oh my God
it's my medical uh cup with the pesto
[__] in it that's right
look at that that's so thoughtful and
the color is perfect it's just perfect
thank you is there [__] in this it's
only one way to find out it's not it's
not cursed
there's sprinkles in here
chunky well the [__] had like a white uh
texture
I don't know I didn't know how to
achieve that oh my God
should we do it happy birthday should we
do it wait hold on I'm not done happy
birthday
to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
genuinely beautiful thank you guys it's
very nice it's a great way to spend my
birthday honestly with all you guys
I love it this is does anyone want to
hit this
is it good it's good you want to hit
this I'm cool thank you
[Applause]
it's awesome
yeah go hit it
nice
oh yeah the guys are lining up here you
go here just I'll give you I'll just
yeah there it's just like it came out
fresh from the source
[Applause]
nice son
[Music]
oh oh we got the [__] tarp out what's
happening next what is that look good
Jim oh my God thank you this is so
special
okay we have uh one final gift it's from
Dan who's been running the show tonight
the legend
Dan Dan Dan Dan Dan
[Applause]
I can't stand him he's Jim who's coming
up
dad dance dance dance dance
oh
when
hit this bro
it's good fresh from The Source all
right
W Dan www
that's true good point
I don't know what to do my answers
[__] on my hand
desire to clean up his hands bro so
listen
we wanted to uh
do something special for the end of this
Ethan I'm talking to you bro hold on one
second
[Music]
it's a heartfelt moment
which way
[Applause]
all right Dana I'm ready you ready you
ready you're good
you're good there's a little bit on my
thumb
thanks
yeah go ahead so listen
we want to do something special for your
birthday we want to do something special
to kind of close out the live show here
you have been working really hard over
the last six to nine months
your weight loss
sure
no way
this is my dream this is like a this is
like AB getting his hundred thousand
play button before he hit 100 000. thank
you guys oh my God this is so exciting
so that's the thing we we knew you were
close and we thought maybe it would line
up and we were being a little deceptive
on the show saying we'll do it as a
thing when we come back from break yeah
this was the plan the whole time oh my
God it's so touching you said
the other day
that you hit 203 and that was a couple
days ago it's possible you're 202
201. let's give it to him people
give it to him
oh my God
so
uh if we could I think um let's scoot it
over a little bit closer into the light
here oh all right what a guy
my guy
and um
let's do this thing
now
won't be needing that now Dan are we
using craft or
um uh I think oh I hope it's not Kraft
crappy trade us we can't use craft to
Ethan from Dan what a beautiful present
I mean
this is heartfelt
[Applause]
that go
wow it's like a striptease
oh my look at the size of those jugs
hellmanns
oh my God
are these the Poncho things
[Music]
all right settle down pedal down settle
down
I'm just so happy with my jugs of
mayonnaise
[Music]
could someone hand me the third one
slave
[Music]
so Dan is preparing this is so special
okay just yeah just put it yeah I'll
hold it
I want the mayonnaise dude give me the
Spanish
so nice
[Applause]
like
dumping 10 pounds of mayonnaise on
um I also have some deli meat and cheese
and bread I believe yeah yes
I'll eat one I'm hungry oh yeah okay I'm
gonna hit that up oh yeah all right so
[Music]
okay
this is happening Dan
I've dreamed of this moment
[Applause]
many a night so I've woken up
many a nights
[Applause]
I've woken up from this stream
thought the Mayo was on his dome but I
woke up wasn't there
[Music]
[Applause]
it was empty
why I thought to myself why must he
torment me
that beautiful round Dome it taunts me
at last me in my dreams
I made myself a ham sandwich with
mayonnaise and I ate it as I
contemplated
[Music]
walked out to the field it was a nice
night beautiful clouds were rolling in
I thought I'd make my own mayonnaise for
the occasion it's so special
wait what
oh sorry I forgot I lost
yeah anyway this is really important to
me
right right
oh my God this is a lot all right yes
slave can you hold the mic please
yeah just hold it for me thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
it's horrible it's smelly huh uh yeah
well if you had hair this would be
really good for it maybe it'll grow back
now
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
oh man
that's a lot of mayonnaise
that's just one jug should I keep going
uh
Dan Dan may I yeah okay sure thank you
I'm hungry
[Applause]
we'll share it
eel is getting in the myth oh my God
[Applause]
I can't see
[Music]
guys
I worked really hard for this
[Applause]
man
[Music]
thank you wait give down a mic he's got
some good commentary
it's heavy it's literally it's heavy I'm
like
which one of you [__] through that
[Music]
perfect I love tomato sandwich I want to
get mail
[Applause]
[Music]
lunchtime
[Applause]
you know Dan made me this promise a long
time ago three hours ago I was pretty
chubby then three years it's been in the
making
and uh
Dan made me the offer that we could mail
up his Dome if I went under 200 pounds
and although I am not under 200 pounds
she is
offered his beautiful Dome
in good faith
and I really appreciate it I mean this
this is really beautiful I mean it's
really meaningful give me a hug
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are [__] no
you guys only get one male or two I
guess I did two kisses this year I work
with Dan though it's inappropriate
workplace relationships are a No-No who
wants to hug Dan anyone else
stand up down
who wants to hug Dan
Ethan
give this Dom a little kiss
yeah that's true yeah
yeah it's asking
hey there's nothing gay about this
all right who wants to give him a hug
let me see
[Music]
you sure you want to get all that
mayonnaise on your teddy fresh sweater
all right come here she flew from
Detroit yeah take this
all right we got a big hug coming for
Dan
here she comes
[Music]
[Applause]
hi what's your name my name is Marissa I
flew here all the way from Detroit I'm
from Metro Detroit
yeah thank you so much that is amazing
thank you for coming
uh well
you'll have a um souvenir you will smell
of mayonnaise no matter how many showers
you take
here it comes Dan
now we can
okay we got a towel for you all right
Daniel
wow all right Mom and Dad come up here
little get a mayonnaise hug no
oh
um are you serious she's coming
[Applause]
here to seal the deal
this is uh to seal the deal it's like a
blood pack it's a mayonnaise packed
yeah yeah
wow thank you Mom I love you
[Music]
[Applause]
Mom I love I love you so much I love you
so much
well
as the show winds down it is getting
late
I know
I don't want to go home either
Jessica and Brian if you if you don't
let us back in your car on the way home
I will understand we'll just Uber home
so wherever you are out there
you okay Dan Dan is not happy get him
can you get Dana Mike
where do how do we where do we even
begin with this
this is this is the worst thing I've
ever done it's such a mistake it smells
so [__] bad up here well what's worse
FICA Fisher man is the
it's the figure yeah
you know I was thinking to open a can of
fika fish here but they talked to me out
of it
well as we come to a close here on this
beautiful
June Friday it's Friday Baby Woo
it's Friday it is Friday
I want to say
um
[Music]
thank
you thank you guys for making this a
very special day for me
Dan is really struggling
what's over there uh somebody might want
to give Dan a hug oh Jimmy he wants to
repent
Jimmy's coming out uh bring him out here
let's get this man a hug give him a new
hairline Dan
a lighthawk cause we love Dan but a
light hug there it is Jersey Outlaw
returns damn we love you
guys are demons we love you
you goddamn Tomatoes you're gonna [__]
the shirt up but I love you come on a
light hug that's beautiful there it is
the guy the guy that hated me but he
loves me so if he loves me you guys
gotta love me thanks Dan that is
beautiful thank you Jimmy thank you
there it is
where's that where's that uh towel might
be having a histrionic moment we have a
histrionic moment all right
all right all right thanks Jimmy
don't be too hard on him he has
histrionic personality disorder uh
[Music]
it's the worst idea I've ever had that's
a clean I mean in a sense I'm more
[__] up than you are
kind of true actually
so anyway as Dan D robes
I want to thank all you guys
it's been like an incredible year so far
and
we have the best fans you guys are so
passionate and amazing and so supportive
and uh I'm gonna need your support
because this Brian Kavanaugh lawsuit is
not going away so I'm gonna need you
guys to back me up
[Applause]
actually yeah let me take this
opportunity [__] Ryan Kavanaugh [__]
Brian Kavanaugh Ryan Kavanaugh Brian
Kevin
foreign
hey did you guys hear
I'm angry
drive angry huh
um actually I got a this is unrelated
but I got a phone call
and my lawyer literally right before I
got on stage it kind of
bummed me out but it's okay
but Ryan I did I offered him a lot of
[__] money to to settle it and he
told and he said no
so wow
[Music]
I said no
he said no to me on my birthday
oh you know
so
[Music]
Harvey you should say that
should say that so that so so
if you guys are tired of hearing Ryan
Cavanaugh I'm sorry because
we still here baby
it's cap cap time
hey did you guys hear that he falsified
a memo that alleged
his ex-president committed
essay to get him fired without Severance
oh when did he do that
I don't know when when proximity or that
was yeah proximity Media or no no no
relativity relativity media was going
bankrupt do you guys remember
he drove it into the ground and uh
it was somewhere and during that mix
allegedly I don't know what do I know
yeah but okay whatever so guys thank you
so much I mean genuinely
a lot of you guys came from far
and went through a lot of effort to get
here and uh really love that thank you
guys so much I mean you guys really are
the best
every day there's a show I'm excited I'm
happy to come in because I get to
entertain you guys and I get to spend
the day with the best crew in the game
I mean these guys are so hard working
so smart
so capable it's absolutely insane I mean
Sam built that giant prolapse in like a
day
I'm not even kidding like two days ago I
was like Sam let's make a giant
prolapsed anus for Howie to come through
and this she made that
yeah yeah they're the best there
I can't
I can't express myself enough frankly
I'm at a loss for words but uh
we are coming back
um in two weeks this is our last show
for two weeks we're taking a little
break we will be back July
10.
I'm sorry guys it's just a short break
promise
but we'll be back for the first time all
of us together oh yeah
that's true
and by the way I don't know if we made
this clear love this [__] moved
he's got the Visa
yeah I couldn't I couldn't have done it
without all of you guys watching so
thank you everyone
thank you
give me a hug
come on give me a hug
hey give me a hug or I'm sending your
ass back to Sweden
are you a menace hater are you a
mayonnaise hater no you like mayonnaise
there it is we love love don't we folks
yeah he's here he's just here now
yeah we got a Visa for Extraordinary
Talent
how can you argue with that
[Applause]
[Music]
mail
all right what
oh okay
right now
[Applause]
all right listen it is pride month
and as you guys know one month is way
too [__] long
I will authorize one minute to be proud
and gay and that's it
[Applause]
so let's go all of our proud people who
are gay we love it it's happening yes we
love dudes and women of the same sex
that's right we are on Grindr and other
I don't know if there's a gay one for
women or if that one is also grinder
feeling the beat you guys just get lost
in the moment they just get lost in the
moment guys feel the music it's
happening all over the place it's Pride
nobody will ever tell you who to be and
how to live nobody your parents
your neighbors your God nobody knows
what's better for you than you be true
to yourself and never [__] stop being
true to yourself
okay and no matter what anyone tells you
if you're a dude
[__] another dude
and if you're if you're a woman [__]
another woman
and if your trance have sex with anybody
it doesn't matter
[Applause]
yeah so that's you know
I couldn't do this for a whole month I
mean that's intense all right stop back
in the [__] closet hey hey back in
the closet
don't throw [__] at me
this girl's gay right there
you see her yeah keep an eye on her
I can feel the devil real name from that
corner right there boy
the fires of hell damn you
[Applause]
back in the closet demons
I took a photo of each one of you homos
that stood up
y'all are [__] Jesus gonna know who
you are now Jesus never forget
hmm I'll tell you what man today I feel
uh
[Music]
I'll tell you what man this drought
we're dealing with man it's all because
of you gays
[Music]
sit
and now we got a hundred year drought
[Music]
and now little kids in Africa are
starving thanks to you
[Music]
you're gay
all right I can go on and on
how we doing on time Dan it's about that
time eh
[Music]
they're kick we do
[Applause]
they we can't
there's no encore it's just me standing
here
[Music]
have your passports did you get your
shots hands on your hearts everybody to
come back with Rob to America
[Music]
I got manners in my eye
did you get your shots
like to come back with Rob to America
[Music]
the beautiful do you have your passports
did you get your shots clear would you
wanna come back with God to America
wow
[Music]
wow to America
America America
wow
all you gotta be is 18.
I guess there's always more content I
don't know I'm just standing here so you
guys asked for encorms there's always
more content I guess
how about um
[__] Oliver tree yeah [__] him [__] all
the Oliver tree [__] Oliver tree father
Oliver tree [__] Oliver tree okay he
doesn't deserve more than that
we need a thumbnail pictures
oh okay good idea
I'm gonna need
uh
I was like I don't know if I can do that
but I did show you guys a prolapse no no
you don't want to see that trust me
you think all right I'm just gonna take
a photo real fast my phone is covered in
mayonnaise
not literally uh let's see if I can
oh yeah come out tati you can take a
professional photo
but I'm gonna take a selfie
sorry you got it it is literally covered
in mayonnaise I can't do anything on a
slippery
could someone take it on their mobile
phone though so I have it
you have a professional photographer
right there
well here let's take one I want to do a
selfie and then everybody together
or we can do together first that's fine
all right no tomatoes you [__]
Savages
who gave you those
bad idea
[Music]
all right wait aren't we supposed to be
facing this way
there you go and then
all right everybody now take your dick
out
hey come on
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah
we're gonna give us a sec here you know
it is my birthday
[Applause]
good thank you there it is
[Music]
what
okay
I just got called daddy that's nice
appreciate that
my daddy now finally
all right this is gonna be the last one
okay we're gonna do a little way to
to uh play us out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
for making this year amazing
I'm so grateful for all you guys
and this is the best birthday I could
ask for so it's really special thank you
yeah
we'll be back in two weeks
[Applause]
Feel The Beat
we're just here for the Bros tonight
again the girls
delivery
oh Gabe's here
all right
[Music]
good night everybody
until next time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]